dereck Swan watches images he knows by
heart but still they make him uneasy
they were taken in Trevor Anita in 1995
Vaughn is one of the Dutch soldiers who
failed to prevent the massacre by Serbs
of Bosnian Muslims the victims worth
thousands of refugees who had sought
sanctuary in the Dutch UN peacekeepers
quarters it was something Vaughn will
never come to terms with people in on
the compound commit suicide
first through the children of the
building and then jumped after them
because they don't want to get in the
hands of the Serbs so when you look
around and you you get a baby in your
hands wounded and you see people jumping
and hanging it was you can never forget
it never know every hello Paul bombs mom
wants to lead a normal life but Trevor
Nitza still haunts him and not a day
passed by that don't think about it
always like yeah every day not in a bad
manner but just a little memory of
something see or hear or whatever I
don't see any problems with that
personally I could cope with their very
good
luckily yeah
he comes here trying to forget pom-poms
might and his family live in a rural
setting
he doesn't reproach himself he and his
300 comrades did what they could they
were not guilty of anything we didn't
have any chance against 30 like forty
thousand serves but yeah well just like
I said the media made a spectacle of it
obvious about us how did they call you
well some cowards or yeah most cowards
like yeah yeah Derek's van spends most
of his time at home poring over
information he's collected he has filed
a lawsuit against the Dutch authorities
he was just 18 when he was sent to
Bosnia now he wants an official apology
there was no psychologist for to ask for
how how it's going with yourself what
the Egypt see do you think about it do
you dream about it
do you use alcohol drugs to stop
thinking and never nobody was asked for
that almost all of the UN peacekeeping
troops who were in sovereign itza at the
time were traumatized many committed
suicide
Derek Swan underwent psychotherapy for
nine years but it didn't really help and
he is dependent on medication as Vaughn
confronts himself with Bosnia he travels
there regularly if possible once a year
back to the places where the Serbs
attack the UN camp this was here this is
the White House he talks to Muslim
survivors he first ventured back five
years after the Schreber needs a
massacre and he was surprised I'm
crossing the border from Croatia to
Bosnia with a guy and I thought they got
a true walk
at my car because the Dutch license
plate it was a total shock for me that
the first Muslim man Abdullah public of
each came to me give me a knock and say
to me you are my friend
after that it's my second country now
yes it's my second country so I left in
the Netherlands but I always thinking
about Bosnia pompom smart doesn't want
to return to Bosnia and the memories it
brings back he wants to live in the
present huge gains an important change
in my life yeah positive becoming a
father gave his life a new perspective
his wife knows that he is traumatized by
what he saw in Sura Nitza
and tries to help keep positive new
happy things try to make him happy
is it easy No Dericks Vaughn doesn't
laugh much these days he avoids crowds
prefers his own company it was it was
terrible situations was the the the most
the most I think the yeah it's going to
be the most hell on earth ready yeah
and you can do nothing you were tired
with your hands on your back and you
have to watch some Dutch war veterans
seek peace of mind by returning to
Bosnia others try to build up normal
lives in the Netherlands but the trauma
they have been derd for 20 years remains